[Musik]
ähm,
Liebe ist immer kompliziert und
eine der großen Gefahren ist zu denken, dass
Liebe einfach ist oder von selbst kommt. Weißt du
,
es ist erstaunlich, dass wir in so vielen
Bereichen des Lebens trainieren,
wie man ein Flugzeug fliegt, wie man ein Geschäft führt,
wie man  einen chirurgischen Eingriff machen, wir
trainieren alles, aber wenn es um
Liebe geht,
lassen wir die Leute sich einfach vorstellen, dass sie
bereits wissen, wie
es geht
Dieser Mann ist verrückt
, aber wir lassen Menschen jeder
Generation sich verlieben,
Beziehungen beginnen, Ehen
eingehen, ohne die geringste
technische Vorstellung davon zu haben, was sie tun.
Liebe
ist keine Emotion, sondern tatsächlich eine Fähigkeit,
und es ist eine Fähigkeit, die wir
jetzt systematisch lernen sollten  das klingt sehr
unromantisch
und wenn ich dir sagen würde, verliebe dich nicht einfach,
geh auf eine schule
, um liebe zu lernen, würdest du denken, oh das klingt
schrecklich, ich weiß, ich möchte nur
mit meinem herzen
fühlen, das liegt daran, dass wir es haben  ein ve  Eine romantische
Vorstellung von Liebe, aber
die romantische Vorstellung von Liebe ist die
Zerstörung der
Liebe. Nur wenn wir unsere
romantischen Vorstellungen über Bord werfen
, können wir anfangen, richtig zu lieben, sodass wir in
unserer Gesellschaft eine Vorstellung von Liebe haben
, die die Liebe zerstört, die wir versuchen
Das Interessante ist, dass es uns nicht freisteht
, jeden zu lieben. Wir
alle haben einen ganz
besonderen Menschentyp, und meistens
verstehen wir nicht einmal, warum wir diesen Typ haben,
also sagen wir einfach, dass Sie es wissen  Ich habe diese
Person in einer Bar getroffen und oh,
plötzlich musste es einfach sie sein und dann
zeigst du ihnen jemand anderen und
sie sagen: oh nein, ich könnte sie nicht lieben
, irgendetwas stimmt nicht mit ihnen, aber wir
wissen nicht, was wir tun  Ich weiß nicht, warum wir
lieben
und warum manche Menschen nicht zu
lieben sind.
Ich bin der Psychoanalyse ausreichend verpflichtet, um
zu glauben, dass der Grund, warum wir uns dafür
entscheiden, die Menschen zu lieben, die wir lieben,
in der Kindheit liegt, weil wir alle etwas
über Liebe gelernt haben, als wir es taten  Kinder waren
und wenn wir erwachsen werden  Da wir uns an
die Gefühle der Liebe in der Kindheit erinnern und
die Menschen
, in die wir uns am Ende verlieben,
Menschen sind, die uns
in vielerlei Hinsicht an die Menschen erinnern, die
wir als Kinder zum ersten Mal geliebt haben, ist
es keine Überraschung, dass sich viele Liebende
gegenseitig Baby nennen
es klingt seltsam, aber du weißt, dass es
so ist, und das erklärt natürlich,
warum wir oft sehr schlechte Entscheidungen treffen,
weil manchmal in der Kindheit die
Beziehungen, die wir mit denen, die wir liebten,
den Erwachsenen, die wir liebten, nicht perfekt waren,
vielleicht war Mama ein bisschen deprimiert
oder
Daddy war immer weg oder hatte ein schreckliches
Temperament und dann werden
wir erwachsen und verlieben uns in
Leute, die immer weg sind
oder sehr schlechte Laune haben oder ein bisschen
deprimiert sind, und alle unsere Freunde sagen uns,
warum du mit diesen Leuten zusammen bist, warum bist '  Wenn
Sie nicht mit jemandem zusammen sind, der perfekt ist, und wir uns
gut verstehen, scheinen sie nicht so richtig zu sein,
aber was wir tun, ist natürlich,
dass wir die Landkarte der Liebe verwenden, mit der wir
in der Kindheit begonnen haben, und wir sind nicht frei, jeden zu lieben
Ja, ich meine, schau, du weißt, dass Liebe viele
Demütigungen hat, wenn du willst, sollten wir nicht
beleidigt sein
, ähm, aber schau auf jeden Fall
ein
bisschen wie mein Vater, so zuverlässig,
also wissen wir, dass es sehr gute Gründe gibt,
warum wir uns in Menschen verlieben,
die uns an die guten
Seiten unserer Eltern und Menschen erinnern, die wir als Kinder kannten,
aber
der Grund, warum es schwierig wird, ist,
wenn man Menschen sieht
Wer kann nur sehr di
Menschen lieben, die ihnen Leid zufügen werden, und
für viele Menschen geht es bei der Liebe nicht nur
darum, Freude zu finden,
sondern auch darum, ein Leiden zu finden, das
sich vertraut anfühlt,
und das erklärt, wie wir
Menschen sehen, die Typen haben
und sie trennen sich von sieben  Beziehungen
und sie gehen immer auf jemanden zurück, der
im
Grunde die gleiche Art von Person ist, und
jeder kratzt sich am Kopf,
warum sind sie immer mit Leuten zusammen, die
kein Geld haben oder
die sie schikanieren oder äh, die
unzuverlässig sind, was auch immer  r ist es
und wir können es nicht verstehen, also ist eines der
ersten Dinge, die wir tun müssen,
wenn wir Liebhaber werden, zu verstehen,
was auf unserer Liebeskarte steht, warum wir
die Menschen lieben, die wir lieben,
woher unsere Ideen entstanden sind, hören Sie
uns alle zu  sind ein bisschen verrückt, wenn es um
die Vorstellung geht, dass wir alle perfekt sind,
wunderschöne Engel, die sich beim Abendessen
mit einer Kerze treffen
und alles perfekt ist, ist falsch
90 Biografien
Ja, du weißt schon, wenn sich zwei Menschen zum
Abendessen treffen, sind sie nicht nur zwei Menschen, sie
sind zwei Menschen und ihre ganze Vergangenheit,
sie kommen mit ihren Familien zum Abendessen,
mit ihrer Kindheit,
alles ist da
und das größte Geschenk, das man machen kann
Ein Liebhaber muss sich selbst genug
verstehen, um ihm sagen zu können, wer du bist, nicht
nur, ob du Tennis spielst oder
Ski fährst oder welche Art von Marmelade du magst,
sondern wirklich, wer du emotional bist,
weil
wir alle ein bisschen schwierig sind und t
Je mehr wir über uns selbst verstehen,
desto besser können wir die Menschen, die wir
lieben, darauf
vorbereiten, wie es sein wird, bei uns zu sein
, und
du weißt, dass es großartig wäre, wenn du bei einem ersten
Date zu deinem Liebhaber sagen könntest, dass
ich ein bisschen bin  So verrückt Ich habe
fünf Dinge, nach denen ich ein bisschen verrückt bin, wie
bist du verrückt, und sie würden sagen,
du weißt ja, ich bin auch ein bisschen verrückt,
hier sind meine fünf Dinge,
und sie könnten eine ehrliche, intelligente,
äh, großzügige Offenbarung dessen sein,
wer  Jeder von uns ist, weil sonst
jeder sagt, du weißt, ich bin perfekt, oh
ja, du bist auch perfekt, und alles
beginnt mit großen Hoffnungen, und dann
stürzt du natürlich in die Realität,
also brauchen wir unsere Liebhaber nicht, um
perfekt zu sein,
was wir brauchen  Unsere Liebhaber sollten uns rechtzeitig
vor den Bereichen, in denen sie
unvollkommen sind, in
Ruhe warnen, bevor sie uns zu viel
Schaden zugefügt haben,
und das ist eine der großen Fähigkeiten des
Liebessehens.
Ich denke, Sie können jemanden lieben und ihn
aufrichtig respektieren
und sehr sein  begeistert
und gleichzeitig  Verwechsele sie niemals
mit einem Engel.
Du weißt, dass sie
aus gutem Grund Engel im Himmel sind. Sie sind nicht auf der
Erde.
Du weißt, dass wir es nicht sind
perfekt er ist perfekt i sofort geht
ein warnlämpchen aus nein
nein du kennst sie noch nicht mal die
einzigen menschen die
wir jemals für perfekt halten können sind
menschen die wir nicht kennen
du kennst wenn du jemanden in der
schlange im supermarkt siehst oder  am
Flughafen
oh, sie sehen so nett aus, sie wären perfekt,
du kennst sie nicht,
jeder, wenn du sie einmal kennengelernt hast, ist
schwierig,
vielleicht auf diese Weise
schwierig, vielleicht auf diese Weise, aber jeder
ist ein bisschen wie ein Albtraum, wenn man sie
kennt  ganz aus der Nähe sind sie auch
sehr süß und sehr liebenswert, aber du weißt,
wir brauchen Großzügigkeit gegenüber unseren Liebhabern
und die beste Art von Großzügigkeit kommt
von dem Gefühl, dass sie natürlich nicht
perfekt sind, wir
alle Menschen sind, und so
sieht es wirklich aus  Es ist wie mit Kindern,
stell dir jemand vor  dy, der gesagt hat,
ich werde ein Kind haben und mein Kind,
mein Kind wird perfekt sein, sehr
gut erzogen,
immer gut, immer höflich, du denkst, oh,
was wird passieren, wenn sie es
nicht sind, aber ein guter Elternteil sagt,
ja, mein Kind wird es manchmal  sei müde
manchmal sei ungezogen
manchmal sei wütend es ist okay ich liebe das
Kind weil sie es sind du kennst mein Kind
und das ist was ich denke wahre Liebe ist
weißt du wenn wir denken
was Liebe ist Liebe ist keine Bewunderung
für die perfekte
Liebe  eine Sympathie für viele Dinge,
die alles andere als perfekt
sind. Wenn du also sagst, dass du jemanden
liebst, liebst du etwas, das ein bisschen kaputt ist
, das ist wahre Liebe.
Sei
[Musik]
fremd
[Musik  ]
[Musik
] na schau, es ist interessant, dass es
nur eine Pille
in diesem Spiel gibt, ähm also, dass Lisa
sich verlieben soll,
aber unser Chemielehrer braucht auch eine
Pille, er braucht eine Pille, um zu vergessen, was er
getan hat,
denn es sei denn, er nimmt eine  Pille, um zu vergessen,
was er getan hat
Dass er von Lisa bekommt
, wird unglaublich
sein. Wissen Sie, eines der größten Probleme in der
Liebe ist das Gefühl, dass unser Liebhaber
uns nicht wirklich liebt.
Stellen Sie sich jemanden vor, der sehr schön ist,
und jeder verliebt sich in ihn
ihr Liebhaber, liebst du mich wirklich
oder liebst du nur
mein Aussehen, stell dir einen sehr berühmten Tennisspieler vor
und wer fragt sich vielleicht, ob du mich liebst oder
nur meine Fähigkeit, den Ball zu schlagen,
oder eine sehr reiche Person, die sagt, liebst du
mich oder nur meins?  Fähigkeit, Geld zu verdienen,
und letztendlich wollen wir nicht
für die äußeren Teile von uns geliebt werden. Wir wollen nicht,
dass
Sie wissen, dass es paradox ist. Wir wollen versuchen
, die Leute zu ermutigen, uns zu lieben,
aber dann, wenn sie uns nur für die
Dinge lieben  die wir verwenden, um sie zu ermutigen,
wir mögen es nicht und der Grund dafür
ist die Kindheit,
als wir zum ersten Mal Liebe schmeckten, waren wir ungefähr
so groß, wir s
hrien, wir sahen schrecklich aus, und wir k
nnten nicht, wir hatten kein Geld, wir h
tten kein gutes Aussehen, wir  hatte nichts
interessantes zu  Sagen wir doch,
jemand hat uns geliebt und das ist tief im
Inneren, was wir immer noch suchen,
eine Liebe, die nicht von Leistung abhängig ist
und dieser Chemielehrer hat
durch ein Stück von
Ihnen bekannter chemischer Leistung jemanden dazu überredet,
ihn zu lieben, und er wird es niemals können
vergessen und
mitten in der Nacht wird er denken,
liebt sie mich wirklich
oder ist es nur eine künstlich durch Chemikalien geschaffene Vorstellung von mir,
persönlich ist
es die Person, die ohne
die Dinge an ihr betrachtet wird, die so gut sind,
so
am Anfang der Liebe  Wir lieben jemanden
wegen seiner Stärken,
aber niemand will nur wegen seiner Stärken geliebt werden.
Wir wollen auch geliebt
und
für unsere Schwächen vergeben werden, und das ist das
Paradoxon, wenn wir auf ein Date gehen, sehen
wir großartig aus, aber wenn die Beziehung
stimmt  Arbeit,
wir brauchen unseren Liebhaber, der uns akzeptiert, wenn
wir ein Paar alte Pyjamas tragen,
und wir wissen, dass wir dann Liebe gefunden haben,
wenn jemand sagt,
schau, du trägst deinen alten Pyjama, aber
du bist immer noch ziemlich süß
Wenn wir wissen, dass wir jemanden lieben, müssen wir
viel Make-up auftragen und ihn mit
langen Worten beeindrucken
, das ist keine Liebe, das ist eine Aufführung, und
wir wollen keine Liebe als Aufführungsvampir.
Ja, nein, weil es sehr gute
Gründe gibt, warum wir  liebe unsere Kinder, das meine ich
zuallererst iii glaube nicht, dass
Liebe nur eine verrückte chemische Reaktion ist, die
wir nicht verstehen können.  Ich
verstehe nicht, nein, wir verlieben uns
aus sehr logischen Gründen in Menschen,
es können ziemlich bizarre Gründe sein
, dass dich jemand an deine Mutter oder einen
Onkel oder so etwas erinnert, also könnte es
bizarr sein, aber es ist logisch,
also glaube ich nicht an diese Art von
Amors Pfeil  Modell, dass wir
absolut keine Ahnung haben,
warum wir die Menschen lieben, die wir lieben, wissen,
dass es eine Logik gibt, warum wir lieben,
wen wir lieben, und ich denke, dieser Film ist
, obwohl er versucht, sich nur um
Chemikalien und Neurowissenschaften zu
drehen, wirklich ein romantischer Film
mit  Er sagt, Liebe ist eine Art Trick,
ist nur eine Blindheit, und versuchen wir,
jemanden
mit Liebe zu blenden, weil das sowieso alles völlig
verrückt ist.
Das scheint mir die falsche
Sichtweise zu sein. Liebe ist etwas
, das untersucht werden kann und Gründe dafür hat
Du musst niemanden zur Liebe verleiten,
du musst Liebe verstehen,
dich selbst
verstehen, andere Menschen verstehen, dann wird die Liebe auf
natürliche Weise wachsen, also bin ich sehr gegen diese
Vorstellung von Liebe als Zaubertrank,
es ist keine Liebe, es ist Bewunderung, Sensibilität,
Zärtlichkeit,
Liebe  Geschichten sind in hohem Maße dafür verantwortlich
, unsere
Chancen auf ein glückliches Liebesleben zu zerstören Die Geschichte
der westeuropäischen
romantischen Literatur ist eine Katastrophe
als Modell
dafür, wie wir lieben sollten Ich meine, nehmen
Sie Shakespeares Romeo und Julia,
es ist die Liebesgeschichte zwischen einem 16-
jährigen Jungen und einem  13-jähriges Mädchen, das
in einem Doppelselbstmord endet,
es ist verrückt, und wir sagen, oh, es ist so
romantisch,
nein, es ist nicht verrückt, das ist keine Liebe,
das ist Pathologie,
diese beiden Menschen  sollte eingesperrt
und in den Stuhl eines Psychiaters gesteckt werden,
also hat die Idee, dass dies romantisch ist, nein,
es ist nicht, es hat nichts mit Liebe zu
tun  zu versuchen, wirklich zu verstehen,
was in der Liebe und dem
Wahnsinn vor sich geht, den man in den Hollywood-
Filmen
und in renommierter Literatur
wie Shakespeare sieht. Es ist sehr schön,
es ist sehr schön, aber wie eine bestimmte Art
von Schokolade, die jeder für
großartig hält, aber eigentlich sagen uns Ernährungswissenschaftler
ist
wirklich problematisch, also
bereiten uns diese Geschichten echte Probleme. Die Liebesgeschichten, die
wir hatten
, haben übrigens unsere Fähigkeit ruiniert, ein gutes
Liebesleben zu führen. Deshalb habe ich ein Buch geschrieben
, das eine Liebesgeschichte ist,
weil ich eine andere
Art von Liebesgeschichte schreiben wollte  ein anti-romeo-
und-julia-buch
zwei menschen treffen sich sie sind verliebt sie
haben eine liebesgeschichte, aber es ist etwas ganz
anderes ich wollte eine
anti-romantik schreiben  Geschichte, die gleichzeitig
sehr für die Liebe ist. Ich glaube wirklich an die Liebe.
Ich glaube wirklich an glückliche Liebe, aber ich
denke, wir verstehen sie
völlig falsch, und das
wollte ich letzte Nacht tun.
Humanismus,
Menschen träumen immer von etwas  die
Zukunft, die jetzt schon existiert,
sie ist wie virtuelle Realität, alle
sagen, oh virtuelle Realität, wir werden in der Lage sein
, eine Brille aufzusetzen, und wir werden in der Lage sein,
andere Welten zu sehen,
hast du jemals nur im Bett gesessen und deine Augen geschlossen,
kannst du bereits andere Welten sehen
Sie brauchen nicht, dass Sie
keine Liebespille brauchen,
alles, was Sie brauchen, ist Einfühlungsvermögen
und ein Gespräch mit Ihrem Partner,
wo Sie an einem ruhigen Ort eine
Hand halten und sagen,
wie geht es uns, wie wir tun, was Sie
denken, wie es ist  Meiner Meinung nach haben wir in
letzter Zeit genug geredet.
Das ist die Liebespille. Wir brauchen keine
dumme chemische Liebespille. Wir haben sie
bereits. Das nennt man Konversation
und Kommunikation
ist
Wut, weil
insgeheim der eine oder andere wütend auf
den anderen ist, es ist
nicht wütend, wie wütend zu schreien, sondern
leise wütend, sie fühlen sich nicht angehört
,
sie fühlen sich ein bisschen verletzt, das
Herz der Liebe
ist zum Bogenschießen der Liebe
geworden  behaart und blockiert
und deshalb haben die Leute keinen Sex
mehr, sie berühren sich nicht mehr gern,
weil das leise
beleidigt ist,
du hast nicht auf meinen Punkt gehört, du hast nicht
auf mich gehört, also sind zwei
Leute in einem stillen Krieg, so what  diese
leute brauchen keine liebespille
sie brauchen etwas zeit zusammen und eine
chance
die gefühlskanäle zwischen ihnen zu entblocken das
ist sie versuchen eine liebespille zu verkaufen ich
weiß nicht
natürlich äh schau ii es gibt auch
schau stell dir vor ob  Du hast zu jemandem gesagt,
ich gebe dir eine Pille, und du kannst
das beste Buch der Welt schreiben,
oder du weißt, du kannst versuchen, es
selbst zu schreiben. Ich denke, Dinge, die nicht
für uns getan werden, werden zu jemand anderem
Du kennst Imago  ne wenn du zu einem kind
sagst ich mache deine hausaufgaben für
dich äh das wird super du bekommst 10
von 10 aber ich habs schon
gemacht willst du das machen du weißt ein ehrliches
kind geht denke ich  Ich möchte es tun,
weil wir am Ende des Tages
gerne unser eigenes Leben leben möchten wir gerne
unser eigenes Leiden erleiden es ist wie eine Pille für
Glück
Sie wissen, dass ein gutes Leben eines ist, in dem
wir leiden, wenn wir leiden müssen, wir
Freude empfinden  Wenn wir Freude empfinden müssen,
wo wir die Liebe anderer verdienen,
fordern wir sie nicht oder täuschen sie nicht
heraus. Es ist etwas Wunderbares,
wenn uns jemand für etwas Schönes liebt,
das wir getan haben,
wenn wir die andere Person
austricksen  Du fühlst dich nicht gut nach Liebe
, weißt du, die Romantik sagt uns, dass
Liebe einfach ist
und dass wahre Liebe nur etwas ist
, das du sehr plötzlich für jemanden empfindest,
und wenn du es dann einmal fühlst, wird es
ausreichen, dich
durch das ganze Leben zu führen und so  Alles, was
Sie tun müssen, ist, die richtige Person zu finden
, und wenn Sie die richtige
Person gefunden haben, ist
es w  Ich werde perfekt sein, dein Liebesleben wird
für immer perfekt sein.
Vielleicht hast du Kinder, die
schön und einfach sein werden, du wirst nicht streiten,
und es wird so sein, bis zu dem Tag, an dem
du
stirbst  und so
fühlen sich die Menschen sehr schuldig und traurig und allein. Die
meisten von uns wollen eine langfristige
Beziehung, aber die Liebesgeschichte, die
unsere Gesellschaft uns gibt, dreht
sich nur um die ersten zwei Monate.
Alle Popsongs handeln von den ersten zwei
Monaten  filme
es sind die frühen tage ich wollte ein
buch schreiben, das die
liebe langfristig betrachtet und versucht
zu zeigen,
wie man bestimmte fähigkeiten erlernen muss,
um zu versuchen, seinen
partner zu verstehen, und er kann
dich verstehen, also ist dies ein  Buch über zwei Menschen
, die sich
lieben, aber nicht wissen, wie
man liebt, und sie haben eine schreckliche Zeit,
ähm, nicht schrecklich, aber eine kratzige Zeit für
Sie
nicht für  Jeder, wenn Sie
ein Buch mögen, in dem es Explosionen
und Verfolgungsjagden und dramatische Dinge gibt,
kommen Sie nicht in die Nähe dieses Buches.
Nichts, nichts passiert, nichts passiert
in diesem Buch
Einige Leute
lieben es, die Liebe nur mikrozuanalysieren, und
das mache ich gerne.
Wissen Sie, wenn ich mit meinen Freunden spreche, möchte ich
Beziehungen immer
genau verstehen, und deshalb ist dies eine
Mikroanalyse vieler
Liebesmomente, die ich Ihnen geben möchte  Ein Beispiel, okay
, ähm,
einer von den Männern,
ähm, entdeckt, dass er ziemlich auf
Schmollen steht, da wird viel geschmollt,
also interessiert mich das Schmollen wirklich, wie das,
was beim
Schmollen vor sich geht, ist faszinierend, weil wir es nicht tun.
Nicht mit jedem
schmollen, wir schmollen nur mit Menschen, denen wir wirklich
vertrauen und von denen wir glauben
, dass sie uns verstehen sollten, es aber aus irgendeinem Grund
nicht tun,
und deshalb ist es in der Liebe sehr verbreitet,
wenn man jemanden liebt, den
man selbst liebt  Denke gut,
diese Person muss mich total verstehen,
also gehst du eines Tages vielleicht auf eine
Party, das passiert im Roman
und ähm, vielleicht bist du ein bisschen aufgeregt
und dein Partner sagt dir, dass irgendetwas nicht
stimmt,
und du gehst und der Partner geht, aber nur
erkläre mir,
was los ist, und du gehst und sie kommen
unter, erklär es mir einfach und du weigerst
dich und du kommst nach Hause und dann, wenn du nach
Hause kommst, gehst du ins Badezimmer und machst
die Tür zu
und dieses Mal klopfen sie an die Tür und
Sie sagen, komm schon, ich habe dich verärgert,
sag es mir einfach und du gehst, weil du
romantisch
bist, und weil du ein Romantiker bist,
glaubst du, dass du, wenn du liebst
, in der Lage bist, die Seele der anderen Person zu lesen
, was deine Seele und ihre Seele können
kommuniziere ohne
worte mit anderen worten wenn ich dir erklären muss
warum ich mich aufrege
du liebst mich nicht eine wahre liebe ist die
fähigkeit jemanden
ohne worte zu verstehen das ist die geschichte die
uns die romantik jetzt erzählt natürlich ist
das quatsch
weil nein  man kann leider unsere mi lesen
nds ist die große Fantasie in der Liebe, dass
die andere Person unsere Gedanken lesen kann, die sie
nicht können,
und deshalb müssen wir diese
wirklich langweilige Sache in der Liebe tun, und das ist, dass
meine
Charaktere langsam verstehen müssen, dass wir
tatsächlich erklären müssen,
was in unseren ist  Verstand und wenn wir verärgert sind, müssen
wir erklären, warum
und wir müssen einfach kommunizieren, es ist
sehr langweilig,
aber es ist im wahrsten Sinne sehr romantisch. Nun,
du weißt, es ist interessant, weil
es, wie du sagst, diese sehr starke
Idee gibt, dass du mich
liebst  Akzeptiere jeden Teil von mir, und
wenn wir ehrlich zu uns selbst sind, ist natürlich
keiner von uns perfekt, wir haben alle
Probleme,
und in gewisser Weise sollte Liebe nicht nur
alles an jemandem akzeptieren,
sondern
eine Umgebung sein, in der wir uns befinden  in der Lage zu
versuchen, die andere Person
dazu zu erziehen, die beste Version ihrer selbst zu werden,
und sie sollte uns dasselbe antun.
Sie sollten uns Dinge beibringen, die sie sagen sollten.
Sie wissen, dass Sie ein bisschen laut sprechen oder Ihre
Geschichten ein bisschen langweilig sind und die andere
Person  n sollte gehen
ja du weißt du isst auf diese komische art
und weise
zwei menschen sollten sich gegenseitig beibringen nun
das klingt sehr merkwürdig und meistens
wenn man sich die meisten streitigkeiten zwischen
paaren anschaut sind es wirklich
momente in denen die eine oder andere
person versucht hat
etwas beizubringen  gegenüber ihren Partnern,
aber das Problem ist, dass wir es so
schlecht machen, wir sind so
schlechte Lehrer und wir sind auch so schlechte
Schüler in der Liebe,
und ein Grund dafür ist, dass wir diese
romantische Vorstellung haben, dass Liebe kein
Klassenzimmer ist,
ähm, und so wir  glaube der andere
sollte uns jetzt akzeptieren wir sind schlechte lehrer
teilweise
auch weil wir so gestresst und
panisch sind
gute lehrer sind ruhig sie machen es
langsam sie beeilen sich nicht
sie sind ruhig und teilweise sind sie
ruhig weil sie es nicht tun  kümmern uns so sehr,
aber in der Liebe kümmern wir uns so sehr und
deshalb werden wir so wütend und aufgeregt und
hysterisch und wir sagen Dinge wie: Wenn du
das Handtuch wieder auf den Boden fallen lässt,
werde ich verrückt, weil wir denken, dass
du ruiniert bist  Mein Leben
bin ich mit jemandem, den ich bin  mit einem Idioten Ich habe
einen Idioten geheiratet und so werden wir
hysterisch und dann die andere Person,
sobald du jemanden
demütigst, wird sie nichts lernen, wenn du jemanden dazu bringst
, sich schlecht über sich selbst zu fühlen, wird
sie dir nie zuhören, was du
musst  unterrichte behutsam
und gleichzeitig musst du ein
großzügiger
Schüler sein vielleicht kann die andere Person
Dinge an dir sehen
, die es in Ordnung ist, unterrichtet zu werden, aber stattdessen
hast du zwei Partner, sie sind so
nein, ich habe nichts, nur zu tun
lernen und der andere geht, du
musst dich ändern und so entsteht diese schreckliche
Dynamik, die
eine Person nicht lehren kann, die andere Person
nicht lernen kann, und es geht so rund
und rund,
du weißt, es ist faszinierend, weil
meine Frau und
ich so nett sind  zu unseren Kindern und wir sind
nicht so nett zueinander, ich meine nicht, wie
wir an einem guten Tag nett sind, aber wir sind nicht
so nett, und
ich denke, Sie wissen, was faszinierend ist,
warum Sie wissen,
wann meine Kinder sehr klein waren,
besonders das ältere er  benahm sich wirklich
schlecht
r  Nachts kam ich müde gestresst von der Arbeit nach Hause
Ich würde ihm ein paar Schnitzelkartoffeln
kochen Ich würde etwas Brokkoli zubereiten Ich
würde es vor ihm
abstellen Er war vielleicht zwei und dann würde er ja gehen
und es werfen  alle auf dem Boden,
das Interessante war, dass ich
mich nicht zu ihm umdrehte und sagte,
du schrecklicher Mensch, weißt du, wie hart
mein Tag war?
Sag das, ich dachte, oh armes
Ding,
vielleicht ist er müde, äh, vielleicht hat er einen Zahn
durchgebrochen,
vielleicht ist er eifersüchtig auf seinen Bruder oder
so
Mein Paar, sie haben Kinder und
deshalb sind sie wirklich nett zu ihren Kindern
und dann sind sie so
streng miteinander, dass sie nicht denken, oh, vielleicht hatte die
Person einen schlechten Tag,
vielleicht ist das, was er sagt, nicht das, was
er meint,
vielleicht  was sie sagt ist nicht das was sie
sagen will wir sind so hart
und ich denke ein o  Wenn das Geheimnis der Liebe
ist, es zu versuchen, ist es nicht immer möglich,
aber zu versuchen, Ihren Partner
so zu behandeln, als wäre er jetzt ungefähr zwei Jahre alt. Ich
meine nicht immer
und nicht, aber in diesem Bereich, weil wir wissen,
wie man Kinder
sehr intuitiv liebt  Wohlgemerkt, wir wussten nicht immer
, wie man Kinder liebt, wir haben vor hundert Jahren gelernt,
wie man Kinder liebt.
Vor 100 Jahren wussten die Menschen nicht,
wie man Kinder liebt
Du würdest sie draußen in den Regen stecken,
um ihnen eine Lektion zu erteilen.
Wir wissen, dass das nicht richtig ist, aber wir sind
immer noch sehr hart
zueinander.
Du weißt, was interessant ist, dass viele
Streitigkeiten zwischen Paaren damit
beginnen, dass beide denken, das sei
zu dumm und zu
klein, um sich darüber zu streiten, also werden die
Leute sehr ungeduldig. Sie sind, als ob
ich auf der Universität gewesen wäre. Ich bin eine
intelligente Person. Ich bin nicht wie meine
Eltern.
Ich bin eine vernünftige Person
Brille ist das schon eine gefährliche Sache
denn nichts ist zu klein
und niemand ist zu intelligent, um einen
Streit zu führen, einen großen Streit über eine winzige
Sache.
Wir sind alle verrückte Kreaturen, und deshalb
müssen wir wissen, dass
einer der großen Feinde der Liebe der
Glaube ist, dass manche Dinge einfach und einfach sind
das hat wieder mit literatur zu tun,
wenn du an romantische literatur denkst
, sagt sie uns, dass die wirklichen liebesprobleme
politischer Natur sein werden oder deine eltern vielleicht nicht
einverstanden sind, vielleicht gibt es einen krieg
und ihr werdet auf dem
schlachtfeld getrennt  blödsinn die wirklichen
schwierigkeiten der liebe
sind ob die handtücher auf dem boden liegen
oder aufgehängt werden
ob man sich so oder
so die zähne putzt wer die fernbedienung des fernsehers
hält hört sich
idiotisch an aber das ist der punkt auf den wir nicht vorbereitet sind
die Probleme,
die uns Probleme bereiten,
und deshalb werden wir extrem
ungeduldig,
und Ungeduld ist nicht das Ergebnis von
Schwierigkeiten, sondern das Ergebnis von Schwierigkeiten
, die wir nicht budgetiert haben
und die wir nicht budgetieren  für schwierigkeit mit
anderen worten sagen wir heute nicht
ich werde versuchen eine brille
für das haus
mit meinem geliebten zu kaufen das ist eine der
größten herausforderungen die menschen kennen
das ist so schwierig wie das klettern
eines berges
oder wie man es lernt  spiele Geige
und deshalb muss ich es langsam angehen,
wir müssen sehr sanft sein und so weiter, mein
Paar,
sie gehen rein und sie gehen, oh, wir werden
sie in fünf Sekunden auswählen, welche willst du,
ich mag diese, das ist großartig  das
ist absolut großartig und der andere
geht nein nein das ist großartig das ist großartig
und sie gehen komm schon wir haben keine Zeit
niemand geht nein nein wir haben keine Zeit
lass uns einfach dieses nehmen lass uns dieses
nehmen und sie  werden immer
hysterischer
und beide denken, dass der andere
dumm ist, also sind sie zu
hart zueinander sie haben nicht
die richtigen Romane gelesen,
wie Madame Bovary und Flauberts Roman
ihre Beziehungen waren dem Untergang geweiht, weil
sie das Falsche gelesen hatte  Romane
Ich hoffe, dass mein Paar koul  d meinen Roman gelesen,
mit anderen Worten, sie würden
sanft gelehrt, dass es ganz normal ist, sich über Kleinigkeiten zu streiten,
und dass wir Sie wissen müssen, dass in der
Literatur des 19. Jahrhunderts
niemand jemals über
Wäsche streitet  Ein
Mikrofon in die meisten Paare.
Eines der Dinge, über die sie sich am meisten
streiten, ist, wer die Wäsche macht,
aber wir sind nicht großzügig zu
uns selbst. Wir sehen dies nicht als
Herausforderung der Liebe
ein Ja-Sager, eine Frau und
einfach nur nachgeben,
weil ich zustimme, ähm, letztendlich
wollen wir jemanden lieben, der authentisch
ist, der seinen
eigenen Interessenschwerpunkt und seine eigene
Persönlichkeit hat,
also ja, es ist verrückt, wenn
jemand immer sagt, dass
wir wissen, dass es so ist  Sehr gefährlich, weil
wir manchmal Nein hören müssen,
und ich denke, eines der nettesten Dinge, die Sie
wissen, ist
eines der nettesten Dinge, die ein Liebhaber
für uns tun kann, und das passiert in einem Roman,
ist sie  Beruhigen Sie uns, wenn ein Liebhaber Sie großzügig neckt, Sie
aber nur ein wenig
verspottet
, das ist sehr nett, weil es
zwei Dinge zeigt,
erstens, dass mein Liebhaber freundlich ist, weil
sie es nett machen,
aber zweitens und noch wichtiger,
sie haben etwas entdeckt, das ist  falsch
in meiner Persönlichkeit, aber sie haben es
in
einen Witz verwandelt, anstatt einfach zu sagen, dass Sie
wissen, dass
Sie niemals eine Entscheidung treffen können, nennen sie
Sie Weiler, sie sagen,
wie ist Weiler, Weiler entscheiden Sie, und
so lachen wir ein bisschen und wir sind
wir  eingeladen, über uns selbst zu lachen, und
eine der wichtigen Fragen, die Sie
jedem stellen können, ist,
wofür Sie gerne gehänselt würden,
wenn Sie einen
idealen Liebhaber hätten, wofür Sie möchten,
dass sie gehänselt werden,
und Sie wissen schon, wenn ich einen Liebhaber hätte  Ich
habe einen Liebhaber, aber mein idealer Liebhaber
würde mich aufziehen, weil ich wahrscheinlich zu viel nachdenke und
zu viel mit Büchern
herumsitze und würde wahrscheinlich sagen, komm schon, Sokrates,
lass uns in die Küche gehen, und du weißt schon,
putze den Boden in der anderen  Worte, weil
jeder weiß,
dass sie in manchen
übertrieben sind wir alle sind
natürlich definitiv übertrieben, aber
ich möchte einfach sagen, dass eine gewisse Art von
Humor in der Liebe unglaublich wichtig ist und das
ist etwas, das mein Paar
auch entdeckt, weil Sie nach a wissen
Ein paar Jahre mit jemandem ist es sehr einfach zu
glauben, dass
du weißt, dass ich einen Idioten geheiratet habe, und
genau
das ist es, er ist wieder da,
sie ist wieder ein dummer Idiot,
wenn du dir die Komödie und die
Geschichte der größten Helden der Komödie
ansiehst  Heldinnen von Comedy-
Shows sind irgendwie Idioten, ich meine, wenn Sie daran
denken, dass
Sie das Büro mit David Brent oder
Larry David kennen,
bremsen Sie Ihren Enthusiasmus oder ähm, Sie wissen, ich
denke an
angelsächsische, aber äh, Sie kennen John Cleese und in fehlerhaft  Türme,
diese Typen sind totale Idioten, und wenn du
sie im Leben getroffen hättest, würdest du denken, oh mein Gott,
aber
das Geniale an der Comedy-Show ist, dass
wir, wenn wir sie sehen,
sehr großzügig mit ihnen lachen und
sie sich in das verwandeln,
was ich nennen könnte  la liebenswerter Idiot, und es
ist ein enormer Fortschritt,
wenn du von der
Meinung, dass dein Partner ein Idiot ist, zu der Annahme übergehen kannst, dass er
ein liebenswerter Idiot ist
, das ist fantastisch, das ist eine Errungenschaft
der Liebe, und
wir müssen, äh, wir müssen zur Schule gehen, um zu
lernen, wie  Um unsere Liebhaber als liebenswerte Idioten zu behandeln,
kommen Sie hierher,
um zu sehen, ich denke, wenn Sie wissen, dass es
eine Geschichte gibt, die besagt, dass
Sex einfach stirbt, und das ist nur
etwas, das auf mysteriöse Weise passiert, und
wie Sie bemerkt haben, bin ich ein Feind
dieser mysteriösen
Geschichte  Ich mag die mysteriöse Geschichte nicht,
dass wir uns
grundlos verlieben oder dass wir grundlos auf Sex verzichten.
Ich bin Philosoph genug, um zu denken, nein
, schauen wir uns das an,
und eines der Dinge, die wir beobachten, ist
das  Der Mangel an Sex
ähm bei einem Paar wird sehr häufig
nicht nur durch mangelndes Interesse verursacht, sondern durch eine
emotionale Blockade und
wie ich bereits erwähnt habe durch Wut durch
Irritation durch Verärgerung,
wenn wir Sex haben, wissen Sie, lassen Sie uns überlegen,
was Sex ist  von extrem  me
verwundbarkeit du gibst dich jetzt
jemandem
in einem sehr verwundbaren zustand wenn
du das gefühl hast, dass die andere person
dich verletzt vielleicht in einem ganz anderen
bereich vielleicht besteht sie auf einem sofa, das dir
nicht gefällt
vielleicht besteht sie darauf, dass du gehst  und
ihre Eltern sehen, wenn du es nicht willst
Vielleicht weißt du, räume die
Küche nicht richtig weg
Du willst nicht vor jemandem verwundbar
sein, der dir wehtut
Das schreckliche Problem ist, dass du
sehr verletzt bist  oft können wir es nicht sagen,
also denken wir nur, ich habe keine Lust auf
Sex.
wir denken nicht, dass ich wütend bin, weil unser
Gehirn nicht so funktioniert,
also sollten wir um neun
Uhr sagen  Gestern Morgen
hast du etwas zu mir gesagt, was mich so aufregt
, aber ich kann mich nicht einmal erinnern, was es ist,
aber eigentlich hat es damit zu tun,
wer das Brot wegräumen soll, und das ist der Grund,
warum
ich jetzt einfach gehen werde, wenn du mich anfasst  nein
ich will fernsehen ich will nicht
wirklich fernsehen
ich bin verärgert und du weißt schon m  So viel Liebe,
und es klingt seltsam,
so viel Liebe wird ruiniert
,
wenn wir von unseren Partnern leise verärgert werden. Wir alle sind
verliebte Kinder, wir sind so verletzlich wie Kinder,
und Kinder regen sich sehr auf über kleine
Dinge, die Sie zu ihnen sagen,
und wenn wir es sind  Erwachsene, wir denken, oh, ich bin
stark, ich bin du weißt, ich rege mich nicht über
kleine Dinge auf,
aber wir sind nicht diese großen Erwachsenen in
Beziehungen in Beziehungen,
wir sind ohne Haut, alles kann
uns verletzen, wenn jemand, den du kennst, wenn du es sagst  An
deinen Geliebten,
ähm, weißt du, willst du heute Abend zu Abend essen,
und sie sagen, ah
, das kann wirklich weh tun, aber wir
wissen nicht, wie wir sagen sollen,
dass es weh tut, weil es uns lächerlich machen würde,
wenn du gehen
müsstest  ein bisschen verärgert, weil ich dir gesagt habe, dass
ich meinen kleinen Finger verletzt habe
und ähm, du scheinst ein bisschen gelangweilt zu sein, richtig, das
lässt uns wie einen Idioten klingen,
aber wir sagen es nicht, aber dann wird uns innerlich
kalt
und das ist die große Gefahr, die wir brauchen
um ehrlich zu sein,
dass wir durch kleine dinge verletzt werden und wir
einen sicheren raum schaffen müssen,
in dem wh  Ich kann zugeben, dass es weh tut, dass es
eine gute Mode ist, oder
es gibt eine besondere Herausforderung, ähm, die sich
besonders
ergibt, wenn man lange mit jemandem zusammen ist.
Wir lernen als Kinder etwas über Liebe, aber
als Kinder das Einzige, was
Liebe
nicht sein kann  Damit verbunden ist Sexualität,
also können sie nicht
unter Kindern und Eltern sein, äh, jede Art
von sexuellem Gefühl, also wird dies zu einem
absoluten Tabu,
und dann passiert etwas Seltsames, sehen Sie,
wenn
wir im Erwachsenenalter ein Liebespaar werden, ähm, je länger
die Beziehung andauert,
desto mehr werden einige dieser frühen Gefühle
um unsere eltern herum
fangen sie wieder an zu entstehen und das ist sehr
schön und es vertieft die beziehung
aber es bedeutet auch, dass wir nicht können wir
sind
wir fühlen plötzlich wieder das tabu der kindheit
ähm weißt du ich denke immer es ist ein
warnzeichen wenn paare anfangen anzurufen
einander vielleicht haben sie Kinder und
sie sagen
oh Mama, so plötzlich wird die Mutter die Frau
Mama
und der Typ wird Papa, auch wenn die
Kinder nicht mehr da sind  Dort ist es, als würden
sie plötzlich anfangen, sich gegenseitig anzurufen
und Probleme zu haben,
dass Sie nur Mutter und Vater sind,
und der Grund, warum das problematisch ist, ist,
äh, Ihre Mutter und Ihr Vater waren Menschen
, denen Sie nie erlaubt haben, sexuelle Gefühle gegenüber zu haben,
also versuchen wir es
Sexuelle Gefühle gegenüber Menschen zu haben, die wir
lieben,
und dies ist eine sehr neue Situation, und
es ist psychologisch sehr schwierig, und
wissen Sie, ich denke, schauen Sie, ich habe eine ziemlich
tragische Sicht auf einige Seiten der Liebe, ich
glaube nicht, dass es eine gibt  Antwort auf
alles
Ich denke, zu wissen, dass dies ein Problem
ist, ist ein enormer
Vorteil, ähm, und ich denke, dass es sehr ist,
einfach in der Lage zu sein, eine Trennung
zwischen
der Mutter-Vater-Rolle und
der unabhängigen
Existenz des Erwachsenen außerhalb dieser Rolle vorzunehmen
wichtig das ist der grund warum die menschen
gerne ins hotel gehen
es ist kein grund es ist nicht der grund
warum
du es weißt es liegt nicht daran das das bett weicher ist
es ist wirklich das du
mama zurücklassen kannst a  nd daddy das ist was
blockiert wegen einem tabu
äh das sexuelle gefühl sieh es einbringen
also weißt du oft sieht man paare und die
sind schon eine weile zusammen und der
ein oder andere sagt dir so
was wie ah i'  Ich bin so gelangweilt,
wir haben über alles geredet, ich
weiß einfach alles über sie, sobald
sie anfangen zu sprechen,
ich weiß einfach alles, jetzt ist alles so vertraut,
eine der Lösungen dafür
liegt ziemlich seltsam in der Kunst in der Malerei,
denn wenn man sich die
Kunstgeschichte ansieht
Was es wirklich ist, ist eine Reihe von
Genies,
die alltägliche Dinge mit neuer
Fantasie, Neugier und Großzügigkeit betrachten,
und was passiert, ist, dass diese Dinge
, die so gewöhnlich erscheinen,
plötzlich nicht mehr so gewöhnlich erscheinen, so dass Mähn
auf Spargel schauen wird, wir haben alle hunde
t Spargel angeschaut  aber
er schaut mal wieder
und er sagt du weißt es ist wirklich
schön und wenn wir geld anschauen
denken wir oh es sieht so schön aus
weil er die zärtlichkeit und
phantasie hatte es nochmal anzuschauen
oder wir mi  Vielleicht kennen Sie einen Maler,
der uns ein Flussufer
oder eine Wolke oder einen Apfel zeigt. Cezanne könnte
eine Gruppe von Äpfeln malen,
und wir denken, dass der Künstler ein
Genie
ist
wir sind
blind und wir sind verwöhnt
und wir sind an Dinge gewöhnt und wir
denken, dass nichts Interessantes
passiert und das, worüber wir am meisten verwöhnt werden,
ist unser Liebhaber
und du weißt, unser Liebhaber ist erstaunlich, was
du für ihn empfunden hast, als du ihn das erste Mal getroffen hast
ist immer noch das, was Sie für sie empfinden
könnten, aber das Problem ist, dass Sie glauben, Sie zu
kennen, dass Sie sie nicht kennen
Die gleiche Vorstellungskraft
wie ein großer Maler, es gäbe viel
zu besprechen und viel über uns nachzudenken.
Sie wissen, was uns in der Liebe oft anzieht,
sind Dinge, die wir in uns selbst vermissen,
also sagen wir, wir fühlen uns nicht kreativ
genug und dann  wir finden jemanden, der ist
sehr kreativ
äh und das scheint sehr aufregend äh und
vielleicht verlieben sie sich in die Tatsache,
dass
wir sehr geordnet und vernünftig und
rational sind, aber auf beiden Seiten kann es dann
passieren,
dass die positive Eigenschaft des anderen
äh irritierend wird und ich  Denken Sie, was da
vor sich geht,
ist, Sie wissen, dass wir über Bildung gesprochen haben
, was vor sich geht,
ist, dass zwei Menschen nicht
richtig von den Stärken des anderen lernen
und nicht sehen können, dass
Sie eigentlich wissen, dass
die bestellte Person dachte, dass
sie lernen würden  wie man ein bisschen
kreativer ist,
und die kreative Person dachte,
sie würde lernen, wie man ein bisschen
geordneter ist, aber das ist nicht wirklich
passiert,
und dann bekommt man diese plötzliche
Verärgerung, weil beide es
versäumt
haben, die beste Seite zu vertreten  aus
den äh dingen des anderen
zwei menschen fühlen sich aus guten gründen angezogen,
aber dann muss man lernen,
wie man das wird, was man wollte,
also liebte die chaotische person
am anfang die ordnung  aber dann stellen
sie nur fest, dass sie eigentlich nicht kommandiert wurden, sie
wollten kommandiert werden, aber sie haben
die Lektion der Ordnung verweigert,
und jetzt drehen sie sich um und geben der
Person die Schuld für genau das, was sie
überhaupt angezogen hat,
da ist etwas  andere
, die mein Paar lernt und es ist eine Theorie
, die ich
die Schwäche der Stärke nenne, und Sie wissen
, dass es wichtig ist, im
Hinterkopf zu behalten, dass jeder
in einem Paar Stärken hat, jeder hat
Dinge, in denen er sehr gut ist,
und wenn Sie sich das ansehen  Die Stärken sind
fast alle mit Schwächen verbunden,
also wird jemand, der sehr geordnet ist,
wahrscheinlich auch
zu pünktlich sein, und jemand, den Sie kennen, der
sehr einfallsreich ist,
kann auch sehr schlecht darin sein, die
Küche zu putzen usw. jetzt, was passiert,
was passiert, ich bin es nicht was  Bei
Paaren passiert, dass
man sich nach einer Weile nur auf
die Schwächen konzentrieren
kann, also sagt man einfach, man kennt die
Stärken, ja, ich weiß alles darüber, aber
hier ist meine Liste  Bei den zehn Schwächen ist
es sehr wichtig zu sehen, dass fast
jede Schwäche
in einer Person mit einer Stärke verbunden ist,
dass die Stärke immer noch da ist,
aber man sieht sie nicht an,
also ist es gut, in die andere Richtung zu gehen,
zurück
zum äh, dem  stärke, um sehen zu können
,
dass die schwäche einer stärke,
wenn du weißt, heimatglas, denkende
welle
[musik]
oh in bezug auf eine affäre oder ja ähm gut
ich denke ähm affären klingen wie
wunderbare ideen, weil es suggeriert, dass
du sie haben kannst
Alles in einem Leben Sie können die
Stabilität der Liebe haben
die Aufregung der Affäre und überhaupt kein
Problem
, das klingt nach einer großartigen Idee.
Leider ist die Realität,
dass wir wahnsinnig eifersüchtige Menschen sind und
wir alle die Idee nicht akzeptieren können,
dass jemand der wir ist  Liebe geht davon aus
, die Hand eines anderen zu halten, es ist
unglaublich schmerzhaft, es zerstört uns,
und ich denke, wir müssen nur ehrlich
darüber in uns selbst sein
und letztendlich eine Tragödie erkennen, einen
tragischen Teil der Existenz, wh  Ich
bin, wir können keinen
Sex haben, Liebe, Stabilität,
Aufregung, Neuheit, äh, Kontinuität,
alles in einer Situation, ähm, und ich denke, du
musst dich wirklich fragen
Okay, Affären zu haben,
sie sollten in ihren Beziehungen einfach glücklich sein
, was ich gut finde, du klingst ziemlich
moralisch, aber dann treffe ich andere Leute
und sie sagen mir Dinge wie
oh, es ist wirklich einfach, wir sollten
viele Affären haben, lass uns polyamor werden.
Eifersucht ist gerecht  eine Erfindung des
Kapitalismus, wir brauchen das nicht usw., also
denken beide Seiten, dass es eine einfache
Antwort
gibt, es gibt keine einfache Antwort, wir alle
müssen in gewisser Weise ein schreckliches Opfer bringen,
und Sie müssen sich fast fragen, wie Sie es
möchten
würdest du leiden, würdest du gerne mit einer Person zusammen sein, und
du wirst viele gute Seiten der
Stabilität haben, aber du wirst dich sexuell langweilen,
es wird nicht so viel
Aufregung geben, aber du hast gute Seiten, außer
diesem Ki  nd des Leidens
oder wollen Sie viel Aufregung, aber
das schreckliche Leiden
des Chaos, Sie kennen die Diskontinuität,
die die Kinder aufregt, also müssen Sie sich immer
fragen,
Sie wissen, dass es keine problemlose
Lösung gibt, es gibt nur
einen besseren oder einen schlechteren Weg  Für dich zu leiden
, also ist
es nur Leiden in beiden Bereichen, ähm,
was auch immer du willst,
eines der schmerzhaftesten Dinge in uns ist,
dass wir denken, dass wir sehr abnormal sind,
richtig, wir alle gehen herum und denken, dass ich sehr
seltsam bin und der Grund  ist,
dass wir uns selbst nur von
innen kennen, aber andere Menschen
kennen wir nur aus dem, was sie
uns sagen, und natürlich sagen sie uns nicht
viel, weil sie
dies und das sehen wollen, also haben wir eine falsche Vorstellung
davon, was Liebe ist  ist wie für andere Leute
und so denken wir, oh,
was ist los mit meinem Leben, was ist mit meinem Leben los
?  Nun zu mir, die gute
Nachricht ist,
jeder leidet, jeder ist voller
Leiden, wir sind nur nicht ehrlich
genug zu uns selbst, und ich sehe die
Rolle
der Literatur, wissen Sie, der Grund, warum ich
Bücher über Liebe schreibe,
ist, dass ich die Rolle der Literatur darin sehe
, uns zu zeigen
ehrlich, was in den Schlafzimmern der Leute vor sich geht,
denn
obwohl wir denken, dass wir befreit sind
und sehr ehrlich sind, sind wir es nicht
und ich denke, einige Dinge werden
wir immer leiden,
aber wir leiden doppelt, wenn wir denken, dass wir damit
allein sind  Leiden oder wenn wir
mit dem Leiden verwechselt werden, so besteht für mich
die Rolle der Literatur
darin, uns zu sagen, dass wir nicht allein sind, und
uns zu helfen, die Sorgen zu verstehen,
die wir vielleicht nicht lösen können
Versuchen Sie
zu verstehen,
was es bedeutet, am Leben zu sein, und das ist
alles, was in einem menschlichen Leben
von der Kindheit bis zum Tod
passiert.  d l  Wenn du ganz alleine in einen dunklen Raum gehst
und eine Stunde denkst, denken die meisten Leute:
Oh,
kann ich mein Handy nehmen
?  Ich gehe nicht gerne hinein, weil es
beängstigend ist. Es ist voller Angst. Es ist voller
möglicherweise bedauernder Melancholie
das ist,
wenn du dein leben nicht hinterfragst du
triffst die falschen entscheidungen
du leidest mehr als nötig du
verstehst dein eigenes herz und deinen verstand nicht
und deshalb weißt du
ich wollte bücher über liebe schreiben zum
beispiel weil liebe  gibt uns so viele
Probleme Ich habe so viel in der Liebe gelitten
jeder um mich herum leidet so sehr in der
Liebe und wir können all diese Probleme nicht
beseitigen, aber wir können diese sekundäre Ebene des Leidens beseitigen,
die aus Verwirrung, Gefühlen der
Verfolgung
oder einfach Unwissenheit entsteht  An welchen Positionen wir
leiden
, ist
ja, schau, es gibt solche Leute, aber ich
denke, ähm,
ich denke, unsere Psyche, unsere Gehirne sind so
komplizierte und seltsame Dinge, dass
wir ihnen nicht entkommen können, vielleicht für ein paar
Jahre, wir können joggen gehen, wir können werfen
Bei unserer Arbeit können wir
viel trinken, um der Tatsache zu entkommen, dass wir einen
Verstand haben, aber irgendwann werden
wir nicht mehr schlafen können, wenn wir nicht mit unserem Verstand ringen.
Sie wissen, Schlaflosigkeit
ist die Rache all dieser Gedanken  du
wolltest nicht an dem Tag
haben, der sich
um drei Uhr morgens plötzlich nach vorne drängt,
also will unser Verstand gehört werden, und das
Beste, was wir tun können,
ist, es zu versuchen und zu hören, und für mich das, was wir
Kunst und Literatur nennen  ist eine arena, in der
wir versuchen können zu verstehen, wer wir
nicht sind wir können nie
leiden müssen, aber wir können vielleicht ein bisschen weniger leiden
mit hilfe von mit den richtigen büchern
mit dem richtigen literaturblick
glaube ich an hohe erwartungen  Ich
glaube einfach nicht,
dass wir dahin kommen können. b  y Intuition
müssen wir durch Lernen dorthin gelangen,
und deshalb glaube ich daran, dass wir eine Reihe von
Stufen
bis zur Wolke des Glücks bauen können, wir können nicht
einfach dorthin springen,
wir müssen, um solide dorthin zu gelangen, indem wir
planen,
ähm und schau, da bist du  Am
Ende des Buches weiß der Held, dass
er fast in seinem Kopf einige der Dinge durchgeht,
von denen er erkennt, dass
er sie wissen muss, um
erfolgreich richtig zu lieben, und diese Dinge
beinhalten solche Dinge, wie
er erkennt, dass er ein bisschen
verrückt ist
und einer  einer der wirklichen feinde der liebe ist
das gefühl wir sind normal
ich bin total normal ich bin gesund et cetera
er ist rabbi der held sieht das ist so eine
art feind
wenn du so denkst bist du
selbstgerecht
und du bist es  wird sehr spröde sein und
immer die andere Person beschuldigen, also ist er
bereit zu akzeptieren,
dass es wahrscheinlich ziemlich schwierig ist,
mit ihm zu leben, wenn Sie akzeptieren können, dass es
ziemlich schwierig ist, mit Ihnen zu leben,
sind Sie es nicht, wenn Sie denken, dass Sie leicht zu
leben sind  mit dir ist das sehr schwierig
das ist ein erstes r  ule er akzeptiert auch,
dass seine
Partnerin irgendwie verrückt ist, aber es ist okay, weil
nicht nur
sie verrückt ist, jeder ist verrückt, jeder, den du
treffen könntest,
wird ein bisschen verrückt sein, und
dass es wichtig
ist, zu kommunizieren, äh, zu lachen, zu teilen,
zu haben  ein Kanal des ständigen
Dialogs,
aber auch um Unvollkommenheit zu akzeptieren, also
sind dies einige der Lektionen und
sie klingen sehr gut, sie klingen nicht sehr
romantisch, und wenn es eine
Faustregel gibt, wenn es nicht romantisch klingt, dann ist
es normal  Eine sehr gute Sache,
wenn es nicht klingt, wenn jemand zu dir sagt,
du weißt, wenn ich zu jemandem sage, den
du kennst, solltest du mit deinem
Partner ausgehen und einfach alles besprechen, worüber
du dich in der letzten Woche geärgert hast,
und sie sagen, oh das  klingt nicht sehr
romantisch gut
das ist ein gutes zeichen alles
was unromantisch klingt ist wahrscheinlich
sehr romantisch im wahrsten sinne von
hilfreich für das überleben der liebe
das ist
[musik]
tag
you